Mark Cuban one of the stars of Shark
Tank apparently does a deal tomorrow
night that will change
men's fashion forever what do you know
about fashion in the first place mark
absolutely nothing forever all right
give me a little bit about this you're
gonna change men's men's fashion forever
are you being serious yep I'm very very
serious yeah I mean weddings and proms
they're expensive they're hard for guys
to come up with something new we always
end up putting on the same old monkey
suit with no fashion no Flair that all
changes tomorrow night on Shark Tank
it's one of my all-time favorite deals
all I'm not supposed to tell you that
but it'll turn into one of my all-time
favorite deals
give me the art of the pitch what what's
the common mistake that is made one they
don't know their numbers two they they
aren't confident you know you've got to
really come across being very very
confident that you know your business
and and three there's not enough energy
in the pitch you know if you're not so
excited about your company then how are
we going to get excited about your
company and then sometimes some you know
some of the presenters some of the
entrepreneurs they'll get nervous when
they get hit with a tough question and
if you can't deal with the pressure of
of us asking you a tough question what
are you going to do when a customer has
a problem and you have to deal with them
so if you can if you know your business
inside down and you know your numbers
you're gonna be fine and then it's just
a question whether or not we like the
business but then there's a fine line
between being cocky and confident yeah I
mean you can't be arrogant right because
you know you don't know in your business
your customers do and the minute you're
air again it comes across and you know
maybe if you've dealt with one of us
one-on-one it might be one thing but
when there's five of us or even this
season there's a couple times when
there's six of us up there then you're
you're gonna get shot down and honestly
if there's an entrepreneur that's out of
the earth this is their life no one's
ever going to be mean to them but if
you're arrogant
I like nothing better than that disease
because it just a lot more fun for me
best sports pitch you've heard so far
with a product
rent like a champion with a giant been
invested in with Chris Sacca a guest
shark and it's kind of like Airbnb for
big sporting event so if you want to go
to Auburn versus Alabama or what this
weekend I was at LSU I'll bother
watching the game you could just go to
rent like a champion and they've always
got a house and every big campus for
every big game and it's a lot cheaper a
lot easier to you know take six year six
year friends or family and and go rent a
house for the game and rent like a
champion he's Mark Cuban the Mavs owner
of course the star of a shark tank
tomorrow night 9:00 Eastern new season
with the shark tank and Mark changes
men's fashion forever
hopefully for good it was so what two
and a half years ago
conversation with reporters when you
said pigs get fat hogs get slaughtered
and they're getting Hoggy talking about
the NFL the ratings are down now for the
first month of the season and I guess we
could attribute that to a couple things
including the presidential debates but
is this a trend or do you think it's
just sort of an aberration right now no
it's a trend and I think it's going to
be a challenge for a lot of sport and
I'll tell you that it based my
observation on my experience with my
seven-year-old son and his friends I
can't get him off of his laptop from
watching YouTube minecraft videos but I
can't get I can't stop him from what he
knows but I can't even force him to
watch anything but basketball and I've
gotten him to love basketball now so
obviously that's a little bit different
in my family but even with his friends
getting them to watch sports is like
pulling teeth it just doesn't happen
and so those days of all you know you
watching TV with your dad guys that
matter you know boy or girl for that
matter it's just not the same anymore
like my son plays baseball soccer
football all the basketball all the
sports available to him and he loves
playing but he doesn't know the rules
you won't watch an inning of baseball I
mean I can't even you won't even go to a
game at to drag him to go to a baseball
game
and so I think that's an intrinsic
problem that all sports but for
surely you know contact sports are going
to have and that baseball has had for a
few years and I think that's just now
starting to translate with the rating
and it's something we all have to combat
but you also have fantasy that brings in
a younger viewer that maybe you wouldn't
have that you have interest in other
games that you wouldn't normally have so
you may not work rude for a team I'm
finding that you don't have that
parochial feel that this is my team it's
more of my team is made up of stars
around the league with my fantasy team
is that a negative no it's not a
negative at all I mean look it's a
reason to pay attention but you know
like you say you don't have that pre oh
girl broke attachment you know most of
us grew up with a family attachment it
wasn't just a personal attachment it was
this is who your family rooted for and
if you didn't then tore real issues in
your household and that that's really my
point when I talk about you know it's
hard to get younger kids these days
because there's always a screen in front
of them
and then for football like I wouldn't
let my seven-year-old son playing tackle
football
you know flag football is right but
tackle is a holder from Beast and I
think a lot of parents feel the same way
why would you let him play because it
was the upside you know there's there's
plenty of sports that he can play
without risking you know concussions to
the level that that football has how
would legalizing the sports gambling
help leagues for the same reason fantasy
sports helps leagues I mean you know you
talked about an attachment and you know
daily fantasy has increased the
attachment with money being these
opportunity to win money and if you're a
gamble so it's just like watching guys
at the racetrack you not just partially
and you're not just you know your
attention doesn't get diverted you're
all in and you're watching every second
so you know we can argue the merits of
gambling and the risk of gambling but
you know if it when it's legalized I
think it will be then the the attention
to the game increases significantly if
we had a vote with the owners how do you
think have you guys discussed this I'm
assuming you have a family yes I think
at least with the NBA I think we're past
real and you're for it yeah yeah yeah
I'm absolutely for it
yep why isn't the NFL the NFL is more
much more PR driven I think um you know
they're they're very concerned about
their perceived image of the NFL I think
more so than the NBA and everybody
that's not true right because we we
changed our dress code and stuff like
that so that's probably not true
all the league's are worried about the
perceived image but I think Adam in
particular has has tried to be not as
try to make us non hypocritical right
because we know there's gambling you
know just happens to be illegal gambling
and we know that increases the
viewership and the connection to the
teams in to the games but you know if
we're if we're not fighting illegal
gambling you know where Ness is
encouraging campaign and and we might as
well not be hypocritical about it and I
think it you know I don't want to speak
for Adam but I think this point has been
that if we legalized gambling on a on a
national basis we can also manage it and
control it and help people who have
addiction issues which you can't do with
illegal gambling or some of the overseas
gambling that allows for gambling on our
games I know that Commissioner Silver's
talked about a game plan for any
possible player protest during this
season to get out in front of it where
do you stand as an owner with your
players and what could happen I mean
I'll tell you exactly what I told her
guys I mean um you know and it's a
conversation it's based on a
conversation my dad had with me my dad
listed in the Navy when he was 16 and my
uncle flew planes one of them when he
enlisted as well and he made it clear
that you know he he wanted us to respect
all the all of our rights not just the
Second Amendment but the First Amendment
as well because his parents came to this
country from Russia fleeing the
persecution of not being able to speak
up you know when when my grandparents
were born I spoke up there was a good
chance you were going to die and my dad
was always adamant for us that there
were going to be times are with us that
there were going to be a lot of times
when you were going to disagree with
people but you have to respect the right
for them to say what's on their mind
and that's why I told our players that
I'm going to respect your right to stand
up and voice your opinion or or stand up
and or take a knee and and and voice
your opinion that way that's the right
every American citizen has and so all I
request is that you share that with your
teammates and share that with the
organization in advance so there's no
surprises and you know and and I said it
originally went Colin Coburn it took it
took the knee that you know there's a
lot of ways that people can protest they
can shoot guns they can drop bombs they
can throw bombs they can you know have
violent protests they can you know throw
bricks there throw punches there's so
many things you can do to make a
statement that are negative and I'll
call and coburn it did was take a knee
and I'll take that type of civil
disobedience every which way because
that is what America is all about
that's what my dad taught me that's what
my uncle taught me and I'm gonna stand
by that and you know what our players
anybody in this country but our players
in this case should have that right I
know when you sit in the front row and a
Mavs game you get to move around and get
stand up get to yelling you sat in the
front row of the presidential debate on
Monday night how tough was it to just
sit there not say anything there was
actually pretty easy but it was pretty
darn interesting that's for I'm sure I
was the closest to him in the audience
ten feet away of that and it was it was
an amazing experience and honestly I
didn't look at him nearly as much once
he got started as I did looking at you
know his family and you know which were
right it's just right across the aisle
from me and his supporters and and
watching them you know their reaction to
what he had to say and their reaction to
you know the the laughs or the cackles
or you know even the applause for him
during the debate was was even more
interesting and yeah it was it was just
an incredible you know almost surreal
event if you could choose between
picking your candidate to be the
president or have your mam's win the
title this year you can only pick one
you can't I pick I pick illa Clinton
what Clinton winning because my kids are
far more important to me than than
anything else period in a story
are you going and I think are you going
to any other debates don't know if yet
don't know as long as they don't
interfere with the Mavs game that's a
possibility I think you're going to wear
your mam's Jersey where the full uniform
mark headbands well Dirk's Jersey out
there on display you know do some
marketing to absorb it all but not not
to disrupt it but that would have been
hysterical hey thanks for joining us and
good luck with shark tank we'll be
watching tomorrow night
you got it Dan thanks so much the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience